vielleicht war es ein findiger putzmann
der sie erfunden hat und jeden fall
erhöht sie die treffsicherheit
diese kleine pflege hier
ein sanfter shops mit einer großen
wirkung
ein typisches nachreist schubsen oder
stupsen auf englisch in ihrem buch haben
die autoren carson steen und roger
taylor den begriff geprägt
ein match ist ein kleiner helfer der
unsere aufmerksamkeit auf sich zieht
unser verhalten beeinflusst mit einem
nazi will mich also irgendwer in die
richtige richtung lenken
wenn ich etwa in einer kantine zuerst an
der salatbar vorbeikomme und dann erst
am fleisch ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
groß dass ich den salat wähle
entscheidungs architektur nennen das die
autoren nicht immer sind die schubser so
subtil um mich vom rauchen abzuhalten
versucht man es gern auch mit
schocktherapie
überhaupt in sachen gesundheit stehe ich
unter strenger beobachtung die fitness
nur ist erbarmungslos und macht mich zum
sklaven meines schlechten gewissens
wahrlich mein innerer schweinehund wäre
einfach zu faul um gesund zu leben
energie zu sparen oder die steuern
rechtzeitig zu bezahlen
vielleicht brauche ich sie ja doch
dieser anstieg sei und darum setzen auch
politiker auf nazis barack obama ließ
sich von den buchautoren beraten david
cameron holte nannte ihn spezialisten
und neuerdings will auch angela merkel
einen beraterstab bilden um mittels an
stupser wirksamer zu regieren
väterchen staat weiß also was gut für
mich ist sanfter paternalismus nennen
das die fachleute
ein wohl meinen das diktat dem ich mich
vermeintlich zwanglos unterwerfen darf
ich könnte das aber auch als
manipulation verstehen als bevormundung
beschneidet der staat mit seinen
anstupsen nicht meine persönliche
freiheit
eben auch meine freiheit und vernünftig
zu handeln
einige leute befürchten dass die idee
des anstiegs der entscheidungs
architektur zu viktoria führen könnte
das glauben wir aber nicht denn erstens
sei alles freiwillig ich könnte mich
nach wie vor ungesund ernähren und
zweitens ein leben ohne war einfluss und
gäbe es gar nicht denn wenig der salat
vorne stehen würde dann wäre es etwas
anders waren soll der entscheidungs
architekt das essen also nicht so
anordnen dass die menschen glücklicher
und gesünder sind und vielleicht ein
bisschen länger leben
motivation oder manipulation
wie auch immer manipulation wenn sie
clever gemacht ist kann auch spaß machen
zeigt das beispiel aus stockholm
da wollte man die menschen dazu bringen
auf die rolltreppe zu verzichten und
sich mehr zu bewegen